welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen I'm Priyanka and the next
few episodes we will talk about mobile
app back-end solutions
[Music]
so today I've invited Jen person to the
kitchen to show us how to get cooking
with the mobile app back-end
Jen thank you so much for coming my
pleasure Priyanka I brought an
appetizing solution with me today ah
amazing and actually I've got an app
that I would like to try this fun it's
called Priyanka's kitchen and it's a
cooperative cooking game for mobile I
love that kind of game me too and
apparently lots of other folks like it
to Priyanka's kitchen is experiencing a
tremendous growth an app store and Play
Store which is awesome
but I'm seeing a huge increase in the
number of files my app needs to store
and the amount of data I need to quickly
sync between multiple users
it seems mobile has its own challenges
can you help cook up such a back-end
service that's a great question Priyanka
most mobile apps and games need a
back-end service for things that can't
be done solely on device like sharing
and processing data from multiple users
or storing large files very true but
here on get cooking in cloud we've
showed a lot of back-end service
solutions what's different about a
mobile backend you're absolutely right
building a back-end service for a mobile
app is similar to building a web based
service but there are some additional
requirements first it's important to
limit on device data storage storage on
mobile devices is limited users need to
be able to use their storage space the
way that they want to for dog pictures
and memes next a mobile backend service
needs to synchronize data across
multiple devices when playing a mobile
game with friends your moves need to
sync up across everyone's devices lags
Ajit dos aren't acceptable for mobile
games especially when I'm winning and we
know is that the quality of mobile
networks varies greatly so mobile apps
need to assume times with limited or no
connectivity handling that offline case
grace
I think I'm getting a handle of these
mobile back in differences like how
mobile devices and services need to send
notifications and messages exactly and
of course mobile backends should
minimize battery dream you got it so as
you can see there are some key
requirements we have to consider and
I've cooked up a few different design
patterns to demonstrate ways to use
Google cloud platform to address these
requirements for today's recipe I
brought along some firebase sounds spicy
doesn't it
even though firebase sounds like just
one ingredient it definitely isn't a
bland solution firebase is a fully
managed platform for building iOS
Android and web apps it provides
automatic data synchronization
authentication services messaging file
storage analytics and more so starting
with firebase seems to be an efficient
way to build or prototype mobile backend
services now when is a good time to
serve firebase family dinners weddings
Friday parties birthday parties
yes firebase is great for a last-minute
dinner you can develop your app quickly
because firebase client SDKs simplify
getting back-end services up and running
but I recommend firebase for all sorts
of mobile backend occasions bio-based
products are designed to scale so you
can use them seamlessly from prototype
to production to top app like Priyanka's
kitchen so why is firebase a great back
in solution specially for mobile apps
well firebase addresses a lot of the
unique needs of mobile apps it's great
at limiting on device space usage when
you manage key value data in cloud
firestore and files and cloud storage
for firebase it makes sending
notifications and data messages a snap
with firebase client messaging it offers
automated real time data synchronization
across multiple devices it gracefully
handles the offline case and offers
authentication of users through a
variety of identity providers well
firebase sounds like an out-of-the-box
solution for many mobile app backing
needs I can't wait to try it on myself
but before making firebase my backhand
solution for Priyanka's kitchen is there
anything else I should know yes so I
don't always recommend firebase for apps
that need a back-end service to modify
the synchronize data hmm that's
interesting you mean example fire based
products handle a lot of the heavy back
and lifting for you so you don't have to
build some features yourself but there
are still situations where you may need
to modify data outside of the client for
example if Priyanka's kitchen keeps a
leaderboard you want to run the code to
rank users in a server that's true I do
need to keep the leaderboard up to date
but firebase does have server SDK is
called the admin SD case does firebase
have a server solution in which to use
these SDKs that's a great question
well one of the many firebase products
is a server list solution called cloud
functions for firebase cloud functions
let you automatically run back-end code
in response to events triggered by
firebase features and HTTP requests you
can use the admin SDKs in a cloud
function to modify the synchronized data
among other tasks so I could use counter
functions to update user ranks yes you
certainly can but as your app gross this
can get more challenging to run from a
cloud function so let me guess it's it
because cloud functions are short-lived
you guess that cloud functions are
short-lived so if you have a small
amount of user scores to process you can
rank them quickly before the function
tears down but when you have lots of
user scores to analyze say hundreds of
thousands then a long-running server is
a better fit in that case firebase alone
will not be a complete solution I'll
talk about that recipe another day oh
you're killing me wow you are right
firebase isn't a bland solution at all
it seems like there's a lot to it so it
can be hard to picture I would love to
see what a complete fire base solution
looks like well I just happen to have a
completed firebase solution right here
here you can see a diagram of our design
pattern and right here is friendly pics
it's a sample app that features examples
of how to use many different firebase
products
looks amazing so what should our viewers
at home do if they would like to
cook up their own firebase out well you
can check out the guides reference
stocks code examples on github and the
firebase YouTube channel there you have
it folks that's all for today on get
cooking in cloud here's hoping you can
whip up something great join us next
time because Jen will be coming back to
show us another tasty mobile app back in
solution if you like this video and
would like to see more such content
don't forget to Like and subscribe to
our Channel
[Music]
[Applause]